[Music]
so hey i always tell people hey send me
a follow-up email how this how your
world's going shoot me a letter give us
a call let us know and we get those from
time to time um not as often as i would
like but we do get them sometimes people
are upset with me sometimes people um
actually that's really rare kelly we got
like one of those right just one
yeah we don't get a ton but we've gotten
a few more lately you'll be hearing a
couple more of these
they don't like me
no that's just james and i but the other
people they do
so this one came in um jane is what it
says this is jane formerly of louisville
kentucky who called last december
because my husband wanted to transition
to be a woman
this thursday our divorce goes before
the judge in kentucky
chris moved to hawaii and is fully
leaning into his transition and we
relocated to my hometown of tampa
florida in april
it's been hard
the hardest part is that chris is
reckoning or revoking the friendship we
had
which is all we had
and what got us through the last four
years
now chris is turning the tables on me
saying i'm dumping him
i'm dumping her
i'm dumping everything
it's all very frustrating and i'm
grieving losing my friend even more than
the final death of the marriage
now chris is saying we never had
anything in common anyway even though
we've been friends since we were 14.
just wanted dr john to know that his
advice has been so helpful to me to make
these tough decisions the final straw
was one on the show the other day dr
john said that kids growing up in a home
with negative vibes
would affect them and they would absorb
it
well later that night i caught myself
making a snide bitter jaded comment
about a cute married couple on hgtv
my daughter got upset and started crying
i knew right then that we had to end the
marriage so i could stop being bitter
because at this point i was choosing
that path
and i want to my daughter to grow up in
a clear and bright and happy vibes home
thank you
so
number one man just the heartbreak
surrounding this whole thing i know this
has been hard on everybody in this
relationship um and if you go back and
listen to the call i'm putting the show
notes when the original call was back in
the day and that way you can just go
click and find it
um
this is a tough call
they uh this couple had been working
through this for a long long time
and they had not had much of a marriage
as much as a really close friendship
and
then things got sideways or ultimately
they they're just appeared at the end of
this sentence
um
but i wanted to point out a few things
in this number one jane thank you so
much for writing back letting us know um
sometimes not sometimes often
um these shows are just in a vacuum for
me so i get to spend 10 or 11
or 9 or seven intimate moments with
somebody then that's just gone into the
ether and i wonder sometimes what's
what's going on
um second thing is
man this is heartbreaking
it's heartbreaking you lost your best
friend you lost your husband
and now you've recognized that your
daughter's absorbed this too and that
she is um
taking your bitterness and its encoding
in her dna literally and so i know this
has just been a hard season hard several
years for everybody involved and the
challenge that chris has been going
through
your former husband has been wrestling
with this stuff and just how hard that's
been for everybody
and now you're literally across the
world from your best friend from your
partner of so many years and just tough
um but i want to
say a couple more things
the first one is this you mentioned now
chris is saying that we never had
anything in common anyway even though
we've been friends since we were 14.
often when we get to a place where we've
got to make a final call whether that is
the marriage is over or i'm leaving this
job or i'm not going to that restaurant
anymore or something small like i'm not
using
that um
yard guy anymore
we often are
so unsettled uncomfortable in
the hurt of the end of a relationship
with anybody for anything that we made
this is our decision that we are putting
a period into this sentence
that we often make ourselves feel better
by
dumping on those other relationships
so you know we quit a job and we go take
another job whether it's a good one or a
little bit worse but it's closer to
family further away
it's so easy to cast that former job in
a negative light well i didn't even like
working there anyway they're crazy they
like make you do the
it was fine when they were paying you
you know it was great when things were
good it's when something else came along
or they let you go they fire you and we
look back and go well i didn't even like
him anyway
especially this happens with
relationships when people have been
dating a long time they've been married
for a long time and they get to the end
and they turn back and they just
look back and burn everything
reverse in
reverse man i'm so glad i'm not there
anymore they used to smack every time
they would eat dinner and it threw me
crazy i'm so glad to be out of that
whatever it happens to be
so
if you've just had your heart broken if
someone has just left you if someone has
just upended your world if you've just
lost your job fill in the blank
and somebody says
now he's saying we never had anything in
common
anyway
even though we've been for instance 14
rest assured that that's part of
somebody who's hurting and trying to
grieve and you're just a casualty of
that grief you did have a lot in common
you've been friends for years and years
and years and years and years
have a child together
you had a life together you shared
laughs together you shared grief
together
you went to performances together you
were intimate together there was a life
there
and often when we look back and say you
know never anything in common anyway you
feel crazy because you think i i thought
we did i thought those laughs were real
i thought that sadness and heartbreak
was real
it was it was
i thought that we had a good working
relationship together and i know that
person wants to quit now or we had to
cut them loose but all these negative
things they're saying about us in the
press or at home or through mutual
acquaintances or mutual colleagues
i thought we things were good they were
they were so the challenge here is
two-fold number one if you're
transitioning out of a relationship
you're cutting it off you are breaking
up you're leaving you're quitting you're
getting a new dry cleaner whatever it is
be honest about the good stuff too
and steer clear of these grenade
comments like there was never anything
here anyway yes there was
i never liked you yeah you did
i never thought you did
it's okay to
no longer feel a certain way about
something
and not nuke the past
and if you're on the second thing is if
you're on the other end of this deal and
you're receiving some of this out of the
blue
just caustic grenades
rest knowing they're not true you're not
crazy
there was a connection there there was
some community there however weird or
twisted or sad or heartbreaking or
whatever it happened to be at that job
or whatever happened to be with your
yard person or whatever
you're not crazy there was something
there it's not anymore or maybe it is
and there's people just trying to amp
themselves up they're trying to flex
their way through this relationship but
you're not nuts and it's okay just to be
heartbroken for a season
the second thing is this kids absorb
tension
and i don't want us to forget that
that doesn't always mean you got to end
your marriage this one in this
particular case um
if i remember correctly it's been a long
long time since we took this call but
jane was saying they had been
they had been technically married for
four years but they were just best
friends um and they hadn't um
had a romantic relationship of any sort
they hadn't had anything other than a
good friend relationship and years she
knew it she wanted to be out of that
relationship and she realized she's just
choosing it
most people i don't
i'm not recommending you end anything
i'm recommending that
um
you take a good hard look at your
partner and say we deserve better than
this our kids deserve better than this
we could we could choose joy other than
yelling we could choose
um to lean into laughter and intimacy
and starting all over and building a
relationship that is going to be great
for both of us we could both choose that
if we wanted to we could choose a house
where people chose
to be curious and chose laughter other
than yelling and slamming things
because your kids are absorbing every
single
second of it
all of it
and i say this all the time and i'll
keep saying it
when kids feel that tension their bodies
react and their reaction may be adhd it
may be anxiety it may be depression it
may be any number of things their body
is going to try to solve that problem of
a chaotic household it's going to
respond the alarms are going to go off
and
the kids will be on a lifelong mission
to make mom and dad okay
and that will ultimately lead them to
make sure their
marriage partner's okay and their boss
is okay and their neighborhood's okay
and fill in the blank on and on and on
and on
stop it
choose peace for your home choose peace
for your heart choose peace for your
kids
and if you got a partner that just won't
play like no i choose anger i choose
yelling because i'm awesome whatever
i choose slamming things
play this for them
sit down and say
i want to choose peace i want to choose
laughter i'm going to choose joy
and with all the chaos that's going on
in the world
what better place
than inside of our homes
it's one of the last places on earth we
can actually choose to do anything
but we can choose joy
just takes a decision
takes a partner
it takes a
here we go
choose joy